yes
live once again
here we go
ladies and gentlemen
i know nobody's here yet but it don't
matter we're doing it live on your
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with griffin
we're doing it live live in full effect
last minute i decided to do it live
today i'm talking about when friends
become lovers i got a squatty potty uh
i'm doing some reviews of some shows so
spoiler alert there coming up
counterpoint the voyeur and squid games
on netflix i went to boston we're
talking about that
um yeah and we're talking a little bit
about the enemies we're not going to go
into it too much but i just want to say
to everybody welcome back to river with
griffin you know what it is
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to uh
riffing with griffin riverwood griffin
live episode 153 in full effect uh but
before i start
um let we gotta
before we really like get going we got
to talk about uh a couple of our
sponsors and i'm doing this all by
myself so you know that's how it goes
it is what it is so first let's talk
about uh one of our sponsors is
manscaped join the 2 million men
worldwide using manscape by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code griffin go to
manscape it's time to get those balls
looking fresh
manscaped
and the show is also brought to you by
doordash
doordash baby
doordash for a limited time you can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on your
first order of 15 or more when you
download doordash app and enter code
griffin get the meals you want cook the
way you want them right to your door
when you don't feel like cooking and you
want to be in a convenient situation
that's door dashed okay
um we will talk we'll hear from them
again uh you know shortly all right uh
before i even start i want to say thanks
for everybody for watching last week's
episode with rick glassman uh episode
152 that one went well and also remember
i streamed it daily on twitch so
make sure you check me out on twitch
eric griffin gaming subscribe there on
my twitch account and uh let's see where
we at screencap you know
you know and i got a lot of stuff going
on you got like look at all my past
videos or you can even go to eric
griffin gaming on uh youtube to see some
of those videos too now uh last week uh
when i had rick glassman on the podcast
you know we were talking about my
podcast and he was like man i don't like
that you have this black background i
don't know where you are i want to be in
there with you and all that kind of
that's what he kept saying i want to be
in there with you so
what did i decided to do then um and
this is for people that are watching
live right now thank you for all y'all
that are watching live uh i got that up
for me right now yeah i could see you
guys in there
um thanks for watching live so what i
decided to do i'm gonna do this new
thing
is
i'm gonna request you guys send me
pictures
you can send me a picture of your living
room your whatever environment you want
to have it from your place or outside
any kind of fun environment you think
should be my podcast background and i
will switch it up every week with the
fans this week
this week it's going to be
um
what is it going to be this week this
week is going to be
my couch
from my living room because my girl
rachel rachel started a new instagram
account called i hate my boyfriend's
couch
and so
there it is right there she hates her by
couch so she started an instagram
account called i hate my boyfriend's
couch and she wants people to send
pictures of their boyfriend's couch that
they hate or your husband or whatever it
is your significant other so she uh sent
that so if you have some a picture of
something that you want to have to be
the background of river or griffin i'm
gonna change it up every week uh when i
do or when i do it live like this when i
don't have a guest obviously when i
don't have a guest and i'm doing my
solos so this is gonna be today's
background it's i hate my boyfriend's
couch and you can see that on instagram
so check that out rachel created that
so it's just uh
it's crazy
uh so here we are guys and again once
again thanks for watching live right now
and if you're just listening uh if
you're listening later on am on any
place you can listen to podcasts thanks
you guys for being there too so here we
are river mcgriffin episode 153 so let's
get it done uh so the simple things i
was in boston this week
um it was great boston was actually cool
it's like you know the clubs are getting
back and it's a little difficult but i
did have this one situation at on the
last show in boston there was these
girls sitting in the front rows white
girls i mean
does it matter
what they
i guess it doesn't matter in this case
but you know it just lends itself to
like you know as a person of color you
know i don't i don't like talking about
privilege and that kind of stuff but
there is something about young white
girls that think they could say and do
whatever they want that the world
revolves around them and anything and
their opinion is the only opinion okay
so let me just say this up front as you
know my set i like talking about
i like talking about everyone i talk
about everyone i talk about handicap i
talk about
just everyone i i not that i talk about
them i incorporate them into my set
uh in a way that i try to feel like i'm
doing it fairly and i know what i'm
doing i know that sometimes i'm i'm
playing on something to like get a
reaction it's not necessarily shock
humor you know i'm not saying something
just to say it there's a point to what
i'm saying all right so i feel this way
when i'm talking about relate my
relationship or if i if i'm saying
something like hey you know women do
this you know there's only two types of
people in the world you know another and
then small percentage of these people
that are either one or the other or all
that non-binary and all that stuff i'm
not here to speak on that i'm just
saying
women are funny they're hilarious to
talk about and they're also very
emotional at a show i love watching the
the different levels of emotions you
know it's like you for a second i could
get them to love me and then the next
sentence they'll be like oh i hate this
guy i can't believe he said that that's
the whole point of it it's by design all
right so i'm going in i got all kinds of
stuff going on all right there's these
girls in the front row they won't shut
up like they're literally talking
through all the comics right so they're
having full-on conversation in the front
row they're talking talking talking
they're going back and forth they're
just like i can tell they're shocked by
some of the things i'm saying but
they're not really paying attention
because they're checking in and then
they're talking to each other then they
get up to go to the bathroom they come
back they're looking and then they're
talking to each other talking so at the
end of my set one of the girls raises
her hand like we're at school you know
what i mean she's raising her hand like
she wants to talk i just ignore that
[ __ ] i mean because i'm like we are not
going to have a full-on because i know
it's not going to go well because they
also been drinking all right
yes i did say young white girls for the
people that are watching live right now
they were young white girls i'm saying
that for college age looking young white
girls you know and and they think that
the world revolves around them okay
anyways so she's raising i ignore her
and then i did so i'm talking about my
landing gear is out and i'm ready to go
i'm ready to get out of here it's my
last show and then i just turned because
they're still talking i turn to them and
i'm like what the hell are you why are
you guys still talking you know and
they're like well
you know your whole set was about women
you know you're just you know trashing
women your whole set
now that set me off
i mean it set me off
and here's why
if you don't like my comedy and you
don't think i'm funny or you don't think
that some of the things i'm saying
aren't funny i'm fine with that
all i'm saying is
pay attention
don't represent don't misrepresent what
i'm saying
because the crazy part is i have so many
things in this particular set where i'm
saying
you know men aren't doing this right
you know make sure you treat your women
a certain way i mean there was a lot of
female empowerment in this particular
set i was doing at the same time
like i say i still poke at i poke at
they they missed
all the good stuff and they just harping
on the negative stuff and they're
misrepresenting
what i'm doing and they just downright
rude
if you don't you know what you do if
you're like let me just if you're at a
comedy club and you don't like someone
just leave or just don't laugh at all if
you're in because this is the thing that
pisses me off
the whole crowd is having a good time
like people are i'm talking about i was
killing
this whole room of people is enjoying me
but you think you're right like even if
you you you just gotta go oh well to me
i don't like this so maybe i should
leave because i'm at a place where
everybody seems to enjoy to be enjoying
themselves you know what i'm saying
it don't matter who you are or where you
are either it don't even mean that what
i'm saying is right or wrong you know
what i'm saying you know if you're if
you're jewish and you're at a nazi meet
and greet
this ain't your crowd you know what i'm
saying
like you in the right if you're you know
if you're jewish and you're at a nazi
meet and greet and they're saying all
the stuff they're saying it's okay for
you to be like ooh this ain't my cup of
tea i probably should leave here
but like it would be rude of you to be
like
you know uh excuse me
this isn't appropriate they'd be like
hey [ __ ] we like this you need to get
out of here you know what i mean like no
matter what it is
you gotta get the hell out of this
situation so
and that that's not even what it was you
know it's like you know it's like it's
comedy we're having a good time we're
poking fun at things and like you know
it's like you're taking yourself too
seriously and you're obviously not in
the majority of the people that around
you
these like-minded individuals who
thought i want to go to a comedy show
and have a good time uh let me go
and do this so you all you all decided
this at the same time but you think you
only want to hear what you want to hear
like like these kind of people young
people and they just want to like an
echo chamber they just want to be like
just say things that i think is
appropriate and funny as opposed to when
you go to a comedy club you're trying to
see
is this comic making you feel like
uh you agree with him or disagree with
him or her and you know that you know
what i mean like that's the sort of vibe
you want to get from this situation and
it's just like
you know what i mean like i just don't
get how
i don't get how
you know you don't understand that
you know but anyway i got but but that
being said i mean i overdid i was so mad
i was yelling at them and [ __ ] i kicked
them out and then the crowd was like
boom and i just got finished talking
about how men don't let things go and it
was so funny in the crowd there was this
woman in the crowd i'm going off and she
goes hey man just let it go and i was
like i stopped and then i pointed at her
like you know what you're right
i need to let this go so even on my
podcast right now i'm gonna let it go
all right so anyways that happened
okay so let's talk about some other
things now so guys i got a this is like
weird but i got i got a squatty potty
you know what i mean
anybody know what a squatty potty is
let me show you what a squatty potty is
it's it's like it's these it's the thing
that like you put your legs up when
you're on the toilet so here's some of
them right here you know as you can see
right there there you know they're
they're just
you know
they're
you know you see it right there like
that one right there squatty potty it's
like so it's that thing that goes
under your feet when you're on the
toilet you know you're on the you're on
the toilet and you uh
put your feet up
changed my life i'm just telling you
right now
we'll not poop the same
ever again now that i got a squatty
potty
um
oh my god guys guys listening live the
guy people that are listening later you
guys don't know what i have to deal with
i have to look at the chat and just see
like some real
nonsense in the chat
some idiot wrote
eric don't even date black women trying
to slander white women
[Laughter]
uh
that i'm not you know what i'm not
slandering all white women just these
three that were at the show
okay
so just get out of my get out of my live
chat okay i don't want your nonsense on
here but anyways
you got to get a squatty potty because i
think it's like somehow naturally your
you know it's smoother and more fluid
uh bowel movement action you know i
won't go into too much detail because
this is like you know especially if
you're listening at work or you're in
your car but if you know and this thing
i don't even get into this ain't even an
endorsement i'm just saying i didn't
realize that squatting like this was
like
you know
i mean the first time i was like well
damn that that that was like a smooth
flow
you know what i mean like this was like
you know what i mean i was like oh man
so
rachel got it and then like she got like
two of them then
you just think about rachel she i say
like for instance she got her headphones
got stolen
so i said well let me get you some new
headphones because she was upset and she
was like which ones you want let's look
at these and she goes well whichever one
is the most expensive
and i'm like what what are you talking
about woman the most expensive so that's
her thing like she don't even care like
it's not even about quality she thinks
that the most expensive is the best
quality that's not always the case but
that's what happens when you're marrying
a princess so she got one that was like
this really nice like uh bamboo or
whatever one and then she got this other
one because then she got another one for
the other bathroom because i was like i
have to have this and then she didn't
want me pooping in the uh
master bedroom bathroom you know because
like the doors right there and i totally
get that actually like that's why we
have another bathroom i like that that's
my poop bathroom so i can go in there
and just be myself you know what i mean
okay my bad some of y'all listening at
lunch you know what i mean you're just
trying to get a little
escape and here i am talking about this
all right
squatty potty
i'm just saying move on to that one
squatty potty go get it y'all go get one
it it'll it'll change your pooping life
all right so welcome to uh you know
welcome back to riff and wig
uh so funny all right let's go into some
this is like just a this is a casual
real world advice from a grown ass man i
want to talk about because i was
chatting with one of my friends on
instagram just hitting me up like hey
thanks for was saying something and then
we got into i was like well how you been
doing and you know and then uh
um
was like thanks for what whatever i
forgot what it was but it was it was
something real you know simple but then
it was like hey how you doing and this
she was like hey i
yeah i'm seeing someone right now but it
was like she was obviously something was
complicated about a relationship so
after getting some details because i was
thinking about it right then and there
oh this looks like something good for my
podcast
and it's about when friends become
lovers so it was like i'm into this
right now but it's like her friend you
know what i mean and they've been
friends so let's talk about this real
quick you know so like and this is from
a male perspective and i just you know
sorry you know ladies out there if
there's ladies listening you probably
you probably have your own perspective
and please you know write in the
comments let's have a dialogue let's
have a discourse i like that but you
know what happens is this is what
happens when friends become lovers man
you know you start off as friends now
when you're friends you have this like
dynamic where you're friends so either
person can call the other person and be
like yo what you doing you wanna go to
movies or hey
can you come help me with this or hey
let's meet for lunch i'm in your
neighborhood it don't matter who does it
it could be the girl or it could be the
guy because you guys are friends and the
friend is like yo you know doing that
now when feelings start to start to
happen when you start to go well i
really like this person this person is
my really good friend i know them and
you start to go why there's some
romantic feelings i have for this person
then the next thing you know you're like
you're like oh man i um
you know what i think i i'm attracted to
this person now this is when it gets
complicated but this is what as a male
perspective
i don't appreciate when this kind of
stuff happens because
so we're friends
we both are obviously feeling something
and then all of a sudden because
we might be feeling something we have to
revert to these like archaic like roles
so now it's like the guys now the guy
has to be like okay now i'll be the man
and i'll be the one to be like initiate
everything
now man you're past that already
if you were friends you're past it and
if you're a girl a female you're a woman
and you're sitting there like man i'm
kind of having feelings for my friend
but i don't know where this is gonna go
and maybe you guys even like did
something maybe you guys you know one
day you were like you know what hey you
wanna you know
it got freaky and the next thing you
know now you're sitting here like wow
we've crossed a line
like now we've crossed the line and now
you're sitting there what do we do next
all i'm saying to to the females out
there is to the women is like
because you were friends it's okay for
you to be like hey
i we're not from we're not friends
anymore we've moved on to something else
and i really like this and i would like
to like let's let can we see where this
goes you don't necessarily need him to
be the one to initiate that because if
he's your friend you know him if he's
your friend you know what he likes
nobody dislikes you you've been friends
for how many how long you know so now
it's time you could be the one to be
like yo i want to get serious and if not
we need to stop doing that and let's
like just continue our friendship or
let's cool out for a little while so
then we can still have our friendship
later but you can't you can't just be
like all right um you know uh we we uh i
need him to how come he hasn't done
anything yet don't wait for that
you can't wait for that
uh and then if you and if you don't know
how he's gonna react and you have to
really question where you guys really
that close of her friends anyway but i'm
saying don't be don't be shy
you know it's okay to be like hey
i want to uh move forward in this
relationship in a different way and you
know when you guys out there you know if
you're in that situation too it's like
and you're kind of just like whoa you're
kind of like like see-sawing and
teetering on like damn i like this
friendship and then you might even be
like wow well this is great she's
already treating me the way i i love how
she treats me and this is great and now
we're having sex so you might be like
well damn this is the perfect situation
you know you can't just have it in limbo
like that either you know you also can
take the initiative and be like you know
if you have to just decide do you just
be first of all just because you can
doesn't mean you should
just because you can doesn't mean you
should so
if you've already done it it's you you
can go back from it you know it's just
going to take some like adult
conversations it's going to take some
like
you know you're going to have to just be
like yo
that was fun
it felt great but i don't know if i want
to lose this thing that we have you know
because we're pretty good friends you
know what i mean and when you're pretty
good friends you don't want to
necessarily
mess that up
but you might want to be like well i
don't want to miss out on something that
could possibly be
but all i'm saying is if you're out
there and you're friends with someone it
doesn't matter it could even be same sex
if you're like you know
if you're gay lesbian whatever your
thing is it doesn't even matter even in
this situation it's the same kind of
thing i'm saying once you're deciding to
cross the line
you know well
really go all in
or pull back
and give yourselves the time to reset to
friendship because you can't evolve into
something else too i mean you can evolve
into being like really great friends and
there is something valuable in that i
mean there really is something valuable
in having someone that knows you in all
ways and then you move on from the
intimacy and now you have this different
type of intimacy and closeness
i mean it really can be special i've
experienced it myself you know i just
think that you know
you know you have to just
find out what's important to you because
sometimes even if whatever that feeling
is that you have when you you're getting
intimate with someone and you think
that's the end-all be-all i mean really
take some time to decide for yourself
like what really is important to you
because that
30 minutes to an hour and that's that
and that's like the high end of like
intimacy does it take is that worth more
than
the other 23 hours in the day or and
extrapolate that to like how much time
that is of this person being a true
friend like a family member to you
but anyway my point really is
you know take some time
to
really
you know invest in it like really think
about what you're doing
uh you know if you've just been a slave
to your feelings that's fine don't beat
yourself up about it you just go okay
i uh
we tried this we can move on or hey we
tried this and let's really do it you
know what i mean let's really do it and
for the people coming in late and you're
looking at and you're looking at what
the picture on the screen right now this
is a new thing i'm doing right now where
you know
that's a my couch that my girl hates and
she started an instagram account called
i hate my girl my boyfriend's couch
so if you hate your boyfriend's couch
send send pictures to that instagram
account and she'll post them
and so what i'm doing now moving forward
is i want people to send me pictures of
something that they want to be the
background of riffing with griffin
because um
this is so so this week it's my couch
and next week when i if i go live again
it'll be something completely different
and it could and it'll be a shout out to
you guys whoever it is i'll be like hey
this is today's background is brought to
you by so-and-so
and this is his or hers whatever this is
their babies room or this is their
garage or this is the
outdoor scene that they like oh this is
a scene from my office wherever you want
to send me a picture of it will be the
background of my uh
podcast but don't put yourself in it
because that's going to be weird seeing
a person there the whole time so just
like don't have a person in it but
that's that okay
all right before we go on uh let's
really delve into uh
these ads
i'm doing it live right now so
first off what
first off it it was um
oh my phone's ringing so you guys you
guys can't hear it but i can hear it uh
where was i oh yeah sorry about that so
first off it is manscaped everybody
manscaped
where's all my manscape stuff yeah so
yeah i've i've used this and it's uh you
know they're the leader in male grooming
uh you know it just depends on what
you're into i mean i don't think most
women are into like a a bushy ass bushy
balls
so that's up to you
um you know
it's like i've used this thing and the
you know it's sensitive down there so
you want something that's not gonna cut
you up
and this thing actually works pretty
good you know what i mean and i'm
listening to me look i got hairy
knuckles i am a hairy man so
i gotta go down there and take care of
business and i have and i think you can
too it's it's time to bundle up with
manscape performance package 4.0 inside
the package you'll get the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer the weed whacker and ear nose
trimmer
and you and you get some ball deodorant
you know so there's some like stuff to
keep those sweaty balls in gear for you
right now right
uh the new performance package includes
the new lawnmower like i said and you
know and it's great it's
trimming is essential for your body and
mansgate you know they threw in two free
gifts for in the performance in this
performance package and i think that
you'll really
enjoy and i think your girl will enjoy
the smoothness that you're going to have
down there you know because i mean
some people like some there are some
women who like hairy balls or hairy it's
like a hairy chest and hairy thing but i
don't think anyone wants what they can't
see
you know
they can't it's just it's a lot
not to be too graphic but it's a lot all
right so get 20 off plus free shipping
with code griffin at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
code griffin at
manscape.com make your balls a priority
this fall
ball fall we're going to call it ball
fall make your balls a priority this
fall choose manscaped
your balls and the people that see your
balls will thank you
manscaped
all right let's go over to doordash
everybody door dash uh i love doordash i
like uh
you know in these times it's you know if
you don't like wearing a mask and you
don't want to go to a restaurant or if
you like they they really have so many
different options
you know what i mean if you're like
we're all trying to run errands we're
all trying to do things we're not
everybody's cooking at home but you can
get it you know
it's hard you don't always want to do
that and you don't always got time for
it so if you don't have time and you
just want to get a meal from the place
that you really enjoy there might be
that one special restaurant you always
go to you like the the whatever they
have there this is it you don't need to
travel
uh you don't even travel far to
experience something new even
for something new or even something old
you have a restaurant you already like
or you have some new restaurant you're
like hey i want to check this out but
you don't want to go deal with all of
that stuff i mean i like that you know
sometimes i just want to go hey i just
want to get hey i want to try a sandwich
from that place but i don't want to go
there and deal with that nonsense i want
to deal with the nonsense of like you
know
i gotta wear a mask i gotta go in there
i gotta deal with all the like you know
waiting and all that stuff sometimes you
just wanna be in front of my tv it's
like monday i wanna watch football you
know what we do pop them with the door
dash app boom order the stuff from
different types of restaurants too from
like inexpensive to fancy
you get it it all comes to you right
there you don't have to deal with
traffic you don't have to deal with none
of that stuff when you're cr
rachel orders donuts you know sometimes
it'll be like boom open up door dash
there's this really fancy donut place
that we don't necessarily want to like
go out there late and stand out there
with all the stuff that's going on boom
we get door josh all right with over 300
000 partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and cheesecake factory
ordering is easy and your items will be
safely left outside with your door when
you choose contactless delivery options
and along with the restaurants you love
you can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered by doordash
get drink snacks and other household
items in under an hour
it's really important guys so for a
limited time our listeners get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of fifteen dollars or more
when you download the door dash app and
enter code griffin get that code in
there you gotta enter griffin that's 25
off up to ten dollar value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app in app
store and enter code griffin don't
forget that's
code griffin griffin for 25 off your
order with doordash subject to change
terms apply
okay
where are we now how we doing on time
y'all get back to the chat thank you
guys for being here
you know all right that's good because
now i want to go into
[Music]
i'm going to try my best not to spoil
the stuff that we're going to talk about
now next but you know me i love
videos i love watching movies and all
that stuff and so i got some real good
stuff to like review but first even
before i even start that
um i you know you know big brother is
almost done so last night because this
is monday it's live i'm doing this live
so last night big brother you know you
know as i talk if you watch big brother
as i told you you got like the cookout
it was the sixth
six black people came into the house
they saw each other and they were like
yo they made an alliance day one
and they were like let's let's get all
six of us to the end and it's the first
time an alliance that was made day one
made it all the way to the final six and
it's also the first time there's gonna
be an african-american winner of big
brother now i talked about this before
then i saw a lot of really idiot
comments in the chat you know like i
sometimes white people love to like when
they hear this kind of stuff go oh well
this is reverse racism they're being
racist you know and i just think that
that's kind of stupid i'm just being
real with you it's kind of stupid i mean
you i mean listen there could be racism
involved in anything if you like it's
all your perspective of how you look at
it but in this particular case let's say
it was all white people which a lot of
times in big brother it has been it's 16
white people all right
six of them get together and they go
we're going to make it to the end
now everyone that they kick out is it
racially motivated no it's this is our
alliance and you're not in it so you're
going out when it's all six 16 white
people we don't care we don't even think
about it because it's like that's the
alliance it's the same thing in this
situation
even though they're common their
commonality that they had with each
other that they were all
from african american descent
it still was an alliance that they
formed just like the big brother that
has been going on for 20 plus years they
formed an alliance and everyone that
wasn't in their alliance got picked off
look at it that way
you know i know it's like
i know it's like you're white out there
and you're sick of hearing about white
white people doing bad stuff you're sick
of it so any chance you get you want to
point out like well look what they're
doing i know that's the thought process
behind
this sort of like really idiotic thought
process i get it you know and in some
cases i understand that there are people
of color who really take it too far
uh you know and so then it becomes about
that as opposed to coming about like
really changing the world and making
things better right i get that but in
this particular case
on this show
i don't think there's anything wrong
with people going you know what there
has never in the history of this show
been an african-american winner of big
brother and they looked at each other
and said how can we ensure that this
happens and they played the game the way
it's supposed to be played
and they got all the way to the end and
now they're fighting each other because
that's how the game works
you know and they're kicking each other
out because it can only be one winner
but they decided to get together and
form an alliance and if you weren't a
part of their alliance regardless of who
you were
because they kicked out an asian guy
they kicked out you know this other
mixed girl like you know what i'm saying
it didn't matter to them they were like
this is our alliance so hopefully we can
look at it like that so next week this
week uh you know i think it's wednesday
night or thursday night they're gonna
pick the winner i believe if you watch
big brother i think the only person that
deserves to win is this guy xavier it's
so anticlimactic he's like this lawyer
ex pro basketball player um
he's in great shape he's smart as hell
he played a great game he won the
competition he should win he had a great
social game
to me
no one deserves it more than him but big
brother don't work like that if if in
this final competition the two that are
left
actually beat him
you know in one of them's uh of
uh this woman azza and then this other
guy derek frazier who's like joe
frazier's son and he's this big fat dude
real lovable i mean he played a great
game for him to be so non-athletic and
lose every single competition he's in
every single competition that has to do
with athleticism or endurance
he goes first because he's out he's just
a big guy
him and i would have been in the same
situation i couldn't do none of that
endurance stuff that the people did on
the show
you know what i mean but he made it all
the way to the final three so i could
see an argument for him being like yo i
positioned myself
to have everybody bring me to the end
that was his design maybe i should win
so i see an argument for that too so it
depends on how bitter the jury is and
all that kind of stuff but
i just don't see xavier not winning
other than him getting kicked out
if he doesn't make the final two
then if it's between derek and the girl
ozza then it's like wow because both of
them
they
i don't know they made it to the end but
i don't necessarily
respect what they did as opposed to
other other people you know what i mean
but hey you have to respect people that
make it to the end if you're a big
brother fan i love big brother
no big brother is fun man for you people
watching live and you're making your
comments i love big brother
it's such a psychological experiment so
make sure you check that out
all right guys so this is the spoiler
alert section of the show i'm gonna try
not to spoil
stuff too much okay i'm really gonna try
not to uh spoil it too much all right
but um
let's see which one i want to talk about
first all right let's talk about this
show first so i won't spoil this show
i won't spoil this show uh too much okay
but the first show i want to talk about
and i'm gonna put it in the background
boom you can't really see it that well
but whatever it's called counterpart
counterpart with
uh jk jake jk simmons i think is his
name um
wait let me look it up yeah yeah
whatever his name is he's he was he was
the
in drumline he's he's you know he he
plays uh jonah jameson and spider-man
you know who he is you know what i mean
if you saw me know him can i move out of
the way so you guys can see there he is
right there yeah there he is
what's up dude can you see him good oh
there he is
jacob says okay so this show is on i
think it's on amazon yeah it's on amazon
all right
i
love this show let me start by saying
that so i won't spoil this show but i
will give you some plot points and tell
you what the show is about love it
okay love it love it love it love it so
counter
part you know now let me just say some
things about the show first
is slow
okay
it is slow there isn't a lot of action
it really is about these performances of
these actors it's really understated and
like everything is like
ah i mean it's kind of plain their lives
are playing and and you know it's like
very deliberate like you know so it's
very methodical and it's like and
especially this character that you you
you see at the start of the show this
character that he plays
um
you know and he is just
really
doing a great job being this really calm
dude who's who's lived like a normal
plain life and he has this job he's had
for 30 years he's he he just goes in
it's kind of sort of like an accounting
job that's the best way to describe it
and he's just going in he's been doing
it his whole life and he's trying to get
a a promotion and he doesn't get the
promotion and he's like yo i've been
here 30 years you know and the guy's
like well look if it hasn't happened up
to this point it's never going to happen
but like i say it's a slow show but if
you get if you wrap your head around the
concept of the show
i it gets better by the way too it gets
better so let me see what this show's
about so in this world
and it's somewhere in europe that this
is happening all right germany or
something like that so in this world in
the 80s
there was some sort of experiment
that went wrong
and
an alternate universe opened up
okay
so now there's two worlds
and there's a there's a gate between the
two worlds
all right and
because of that each world discovered
the other world and then they realized
yo we need to keep this a secret
and we need to control this
so that so it's almost like a border
patrol on each side you know they have
this whole thing where you have to have
a passport and you have to you know you
go into the other world but the worlds
are the same so there's like
there would be like two eric griffins
and that other griffin we're living our
lives pretty much the same we're
identical it's an alternate universe
it's like the multiverse but there's two
you know and in this multiverse like i
say there's two organizations one on
each side and then they share
information with each other because the
worlds are the same and then they sort
of branch off so in one world
like the cell phones are better in
another world they cured something you
know in one world for instance prince is
alive and in the other world prince is
dead you know what i mean
so something happened in one of the
worlds where there was some sort of
virus
that wiped out a billion people
so they're still recovering from that in
that universe and in the other universe
they have other things going on and the
one universe is blaming the other for
this virus
even though it's been disproved that's
what they say in the show but you'll
find that out later
i'm not spoiling anything for the show
right now that's basically what the show
is about
uh and so what ends up happening is
jk
you know the star
he meets his counterpart
who also
they they work for the same they both
work for the organization that keeps
this a secret and controls the the gate
the gate crossing
and so it becomes a show about
there's like espionage and you know it's
a lot of politics you know it becomes
like
you know they they share information
with each other but it's like it's very
like political you know and so when you
get all of this
you get all of that intrigue about why
they're doing this and like i say it can
be slow
like in one show one show in one
universe the guy the main character
his wife was hit by a car and she's in a
coma
you know and in the other universe you
know it's that didn't happen so you know
what i mean and you can see like when
these guys meet each other and they
start talking about their lives their
lives
you know they're the same person but
they lived a different life and it's
just like you really wrap your brain
around all that stuff but i don't know
man i just i really enjoy it and i don't
want to spoil it too much but i i'm
having this it's going on right now so
i'm all caught up on like season i mean
episode six or seven i think it's only
10 episodes
uh i think they're still coming i think
they're all out already so
if you like a a good you know
adult drama
uh that about interrelation
interpersonal relationships uh you know
with like some spy stuff on the outside
this is the show for you so once again
counterpart
uh season one with jk simmons
uh is that his name jk simmons i don't
know if that's his name whatever you
guys will look it up but i really enjoy
this show i give it a you know
i give it a griffin thumbs up
so it's it's really good and so it's
like they i don't know man i just they
like i said i love this idea of like
these two different universes i've gone
on different paths like there was a
point where something happened and they
branched off and it's different worlds
you know
and it's like you know like in the spy
stuff it's like so like when like it's
like
when someone comes from the other world
to the other one this like secret like
underground
organization who's trying to like cause
havoc you know they got to come over and
part and they want to take over the you
know the role of their counterpart and
they end up and they they end up having
to kill that person and then take over
their life i mean it's it's stuff like
that going on and then you could just
see and you see how their lives are
different and it's like how did their
lives become different even though they
are the same person i mean it's really
fascinating to sometimes
sometimes there's a concept of a show
that is greater than the actual show or
a movie
let me give you a great example of that
is uh in time with justin timberlake i
thought the concept of that movie was
way better executed than the actual
movie in this case i'll say with
counterpart
like i think the concept is still better
than the show but the show's pretty good
all right it's pretty good so i
recommend it and if you've watched it
you know give me some comments on what
you think about the show but i really
really enjoyed it okay
all right so there's that
counter
part on amazon
all right so now
let's go spoiler i'm giving you spoiler
right now for this one this is a spoiler
alert for this movie and this is a movie
that is also on amazon and it's called
the voyeurs all right i don't know who
stars in it this guy right here though
that stars in it he's in a show also on
hbo called generations
and he plays this really like flamboyant
gay guy in that show and in this show
he's it's just a testament to his act
he's actually a really great actor
because
i i when i didn't recognize him at first
and i was like oh man that's the dude
from generations and he's now he's
playing a straight character and he's
like doing a great job there too so
testament to his acting
okay
i'm spoiling this movie
[Laughter]
i'm just telling you right now spoiler
alert if you have not watched voyeur
okay then you might want to stop
listening right now and go watch it
yourself
but if you don't care
uh then this movie is bananas man this
is a bananas movie that i want to say
this is a guilty pleasure movie meaning
it was not good okay but i enjoyed the
[ __ ] out of
enjoying how not good it was all right
and like i say the performances the
performances were good enough it's just
the craziest stuff was happening in this
movie so like
crazy stuff is happening and then they
try to justify the crazy stuff that
happens with something crazy and then
that is justified with something crazy
and then you realize there's like a
trick and then you go oh man i didn't
know that was happening and then you
have to go back in your head and be like
oh that's why this happened this
happened this happened okay so let's go
over this movie spoiler alert let me get
my singing mic out spoiler alert
all right i don't know any has anybody
seen this
you listen i see people in the chat
already saying this movie sucks if you
saw it i i 100 agree with you i think
this movie is terrible but at the same
time i say watch it because it's really
it's craziness
okay so all right the movie opens up
with this couple they move into a loft
in like new yorkers i think it's new
york but it doesn't matter it's a
metropolitan city okay they they live in
this beautiful loft like i don't believe
that they can afford it okay the guy is
like a jingle he's a musician but he's
doing jingles for commercials the woman
is like an optometrist so she works it
like maybe they could afford it i mean
those are two pretty good jobs so it's
probably really expensive loft you know
they sign their lease and they live in
this loft they obviously have this
really great little romance there's the
two of them right there there's her
you've seen her in other things and i
said well you've seen this guy i don't
know their names i don't really care you
can look it up your damn self
but it is a fun watch okay so they move
into this loft all right so they're in
the loft so then you know they're this
interesting couple they're like a young
couple but who are now professionals so
they're in between like late 20s
you know being like i want to party but
they're like also like adults who like
it's time to start thinking about having
kids and moving on with our lives but
she's kind of like i still want to party
and he's like well okay i love you and
this and that so
they look at their big glass windows and
they can see into everybody's place the
the lofts across the way so they look
over and they see a couple a really
attractive couple okay
and they start having sex and these two
are like whoa they see the sex happening
and they're really excited about the sex
you know and it's kind of like
interesting and that's what they're
being voyeurs and then it just goes on
and on and on where now they see that
the guy actually is a photographer but
he's also a player because women keep
coming to his loft when his wife's out
of town or his wife's gone and he does
the same move he takes pictures of the
chicks and then he's like he's like hey
you know maybe you should take your uh
shirt off and you know and he's like he
takes his shirt off to make them
comfortable next thing you know he's
going down on the on the model okay and
they see this happening and they're like
whoa and then they see you know and then
they're like wow what's going on and
then they think
and then they see that he's cheating on
his wife
you know what i mean and then now
they're really getting into it they're
like she goes and gets binoculars and
they're looking in you know and then
they get kind of freaky with it where
she's kind of like hey oh and they also
set up how
you know
she's obviously not uh satisfied
sexually by her boyfriend husband i
don't know if they're married or not and
they keep they set that up by like you
know she's all sexy and ready and he she
gets in bed and he's sleeping so then
she's looking at this sort of like
this hot sexy couple and this dude who
she's clearly attracted to is having sex
and and the way she wants to have sex so
like she's looking in her binoculars and
then she goes hey you look she she gives
a binoculars to the dude and he's
looking and then she starts like
you know messing with him she reached
gives him a reach around you know what i
mean and he's all like oh wow and then
she like says my turn now you know what
i mean and then uh you know you know
she's looking and then she you know the
guy's having sex with her while she's
looking and she's like slow down and
she's like
but she's looking through the binoculars
and she's imagining that
um
uh
it's this guy you could tell you know
and then it's like this is a thing
that's happening all right so now but
the dude is kind of like yo i think you
need to stop watching this now but at
the same time she's now like hey we do
we need do we say something so now they
want to hear what's going on okay so
they have some convoluted way that they
can like you know he could bounce the
signals off the thing and you know so
they have like a laser pointer where you
can like you know listen in but he's
like what the signal needs to be bounced
back and then you know he has the
machinery because he's like remember
he's like you know in the music so he's
got the sound tech stuff so they figure
a way to do this they have to go to the
so this guy the people are throwing a
party
so they they they crash the party and
they put like a little mirror in a spot
you know behind something that they can
see and they bounce the reflection off
and so now they can hear what's going on
okay
so now you can see like they start to
feel bad for the wife you know and by
the way like i said spoiler alert if
you're listening just a spoiler i told
you from the jump if you're just coming
in now and you're listening live i'm
spoiling the movie voyeur it is what it
is all right jimmy thanks for being a uh
uh uh
you know whatever egghead on here you
know keep doing the if you want to be a
member i'm trying i'm going to start
doing some original content i swear to
god if you want to be on patreon too
make sure you go to patreon so anyway
all right so it works now they can hear
okay so this so at this point it's all
kind of like what the hell's happening
in this movie all right
so then the girl
the the girl um
[Music]
you know
they they had they make up names and
then they go to this party and then the
girl is like like she's a character with
that same name so that's a little weird
where you're like wow how'd that happen
you know and then the girl the wife
the wife shows up at the optometrist
office the girl and she's like hey i
need to get glasses like what are the
odds you know what i mean in a big city
like this you're like wow wow so then
it's like you and then and then the
girls kind of like they hit it off and
she's like hey we should hang out so
then they go hang out and then like the
girl's telling her the wife's saying
like oh yeah i'm having trouble it's
like my husband is like i quit modeling
and he's my whole world and all this
stuff and then now the girl feels bad
now the girl feels like man the dude's
cheating what do i do and then the
husband's like yo this ain't your
business i think you should just leave
this alone i think this has gone too far
all right so then they have like you
know how like when you say you want to
print something
you want to print something and then
people's other people's printers show up
you ever seen that thing you know even
when you're at a hotel that happens it
goes like a printer like you know you're
at a hotel and the business is around
you go printer but you can't usually
print to it but in this universe she
figures out that she sees the wife
sitting on the couch you know and she
likes this wife now and she
she wants to tell the wife your husband
is cheating on you you know and this is
the thing too he just saw the husband
cheating so the husband cheats he has a
threesome with two models and he takes
the condom off and he puts it in the
bathroom uh trash can right and so then
she sees this so now she's sending the
printer she sends over you know
information on the printer like your
husband's cheating on you and she's like
check the bathroom
trash can there's a used condom you know
and so the wife finds the condom and
she's like oh my god it's true he's
cheating you know what i mean because oh
by the way the husband they already had
it out they already had a fight about
them cheating and the husband treated
her like you're crazy you know and he
turned it around on her and she's like
apologizing for thinking he's cheating
and like you know he's really a dick
like the dude's a dick okay anyways
she sees the condom now she's mad she
goes to get a knife from the from the
kitchen
now the couple that is watching
the dude's like what are you what we got
to call the cops we can't let her we
can't watch this woman kill this dude
and then she's like oh my god what are
we going to do because they're illegally
watching them right
she goes to the bedroom she almost stabs
them but she doesn't and then they start
talking and she goes you know what i'm
sorry we're never gonna do this again
we're done we're done we're done okay
and then they look out
then as they're talking and having this
moment they look out the wife
had killed herself
the wife slit her own throat or whatever
it is like that so the husband's like oh
my god so now they're devastated you
know that that couple that's been
watching is like oh my god what did we
do we killed this woman because of what
we did and he's like i told you to leave
her alone i told you and he's like i
don't know you anymore and he leaves the
dude leaves this dude right
not just dude this dude he leaves okay
he leaves and then she's now like
devastated you know what i'm saying this
the woman's devastated but she's also
obsessed with this guy so then cut to
now she goes
and it follows him she meets him at a
bar they start having a conversation cut
two this guy's like can i take your
picture and he takes her back to his
hotel to his that same loft he takes her
back
and and by the way a lot of nudity in
this movie for no damn reason i'm all
about nudity when it like services this
the story i want it to be realistic you
know what i mean but this was just like
let me show these titties for no damn
reason it was just titties for no damn
reason so
he seduces her they have this thing they
have sex okay so they're having sex in
the loft she's finally having sex with
this guy even though
because of her and everything the
woman's dead so all right the boyfriend
now this dude he comes back with flowers
to apologize to his his girl i was hasty
i shouldn't have left right
of course he sees his woman having sex
with this guy
when she comes back to the loft
he hung himself
okay
so now at this point i'm like
what
like all this is ridiculous i'm like are
you kidding me what is happening in this
show it's all ridiculous so now she's
devastated her man is dead she killed
the other wife because she was being too
nosy now she alone got nobody
she tells her friend at the optometrist
office they go to lunch and she's like
it's not your fault girl this thing your
fault okay i hope you're following along
guys this is like
i know this is crazy maybe you're
listening at work or you're like
watching right now you're just like what
is this guy talking about but i'm just
telling this movie was so crazy i had to
talk about it like this okay so this is
what happens at this point okay uh you
know she says i have to
i have to like see him again
so he's a big time photographer so he
has this art show that he's gonna do she
shows up to the art show he sees her and
he's like hey thanks for coming you know
what i mean because they they have sex
and it seems to be like they had a
connection so he goes up and he's like
thank you everyone for being here
i want to thank the person that made
this possible
and he thanks his wife who we think is
dead
but in walks the wife
now the girl is in the crowd like what
the wife's not dead and they're up there
like and and now they present
the show
the picture show okay and what the show
is
it's
the girl and the boyfriend
they show her naked with her titties out
they show them
watching
them
they've been recording them the whole
time they've been recording them
watching them
it's this was a whole setup and then
they show the guy that hung himself and
they're like everybody's like
it's a big shock so now you're like what
mind blown this is all a big game and so
then it turns out that
this hot couple the photographer and the
hot model they set this whole thing up
they actually own that loft and in the
lease
that these people didn't read they just
signed in the lease it says
you will be recorded 24 hours a day or
whatever it is so the girl rushes back
to her loft she's so upset because she
sees the angles that all these pictures
have been taken and then she finds a
hidden room in her loft with a bunch of
cameras and stuff and it's like it's a
whole big thing she destroys everything
in there and now her life is like she's
like i can't believe this happened
because her man is dead
okay
throughout the show
they have the guy was drinking like uh
you know he was drinking some like
chloroform water it was nasty he pours
it into this bird
bird uh sanctuary thing because birds
come and drink water
now she's looking out
she's moving you know now she's gotta
move she looks out the loft and the
couple's sitting there and the woman
waves at her like hey
you know and then they they show them on
like a talk show because people are
furious with them because he's like you
know you caused the man's death and
they're like hey they should they should
have read the lease it's not our fault
it's a tragedy but it's all for the sake
of art right that's what they say so but
then now so the girl is looking out the
girl's waving to her like what a [ __ ]
right waving at her and then she sees
that there are dead birds
okay and she realizes that this water
there's dead birds she was like wait
this this isn't right and then she
thinks about her man and she goes my man
never would have killed himself
so now she puts it together that she
thinks these people
set this whole thing up
so she now
you know
sends them wine
but they don't know it's from her
and then it's like the wine is poisoned
or whatever
and they
you know she she calls them and they're
like what are you doing and then they
chase her
and she leads them to the optometrist
office okay
and then she she goes i know you
poisoned my man i know you poisoned him
and set up to set it up to make it look
like he killed himself which is like so
ridiculous right
she then
they pass out
she puts them in the optometrist chair
and she blinds them
she blinds them and that's the end of
the movie they're sitting in the loft
blind and then she she gets off
scot-free
the most convoluted
ridiculous
triple twist nonsense
even though i've spoiled the whole thing
for you you gotta go watch it
oh man
all right
next one and last one i've gone so long
i don't even know i was going to talk
about that one for so long
all right but last one i want to talk
about and i won't spoil this one but i
guess if you've listened this long you
know
you might be like whatever but i want to
talk about this show it's called squid
games it's a korean show and it's on
netflix and i'm telling you
this sucker is
great i really enjoy this movie it's on
it's a show on netflix it's a korean
show
so
i don't know how you guys do it but i
listen in english so i like to get the
dubbed version because i hate reading
but i probably think that the korean
version is better it feels more natural
because sometimes with these korean
shows
or the acting sometimes it's a little
bit over the top you know it's really
big
you know and every big big movements and
they're just big they're just like it's
a big you know they push for the comedy
so there is a little bit of that
but and then when you hear the dubbed
version the english actor is like trying
to mimic what they see on the screen so
it could be a little bit ridiculous
but
this is but it gets better so i won't
spoil the squid games but i will tell
you like what it's about um
you know so squid games is about like so
this guy the guy on the um the the main
this guy right here at 456
he's
we're following him and he's a
degenerate gambler
you know he loves his kid but he's not a
good father you know his wife left him
so she's got another you know and she
gets to see his daughter you know what i
mean he lives with his mom and his poor
mom has to do all this work and he like
you know he steals money from his mom
and he's just a degenerate you know so
he runs into a guy on the street at the
train station who says to him he has a
briefcase full of money and he goes hey
let's play a game right now and every
time you beat me i'll give you uh you
know a lot of money uh and every time
you lose i get to slap you you know what
i mean so he gives them you know this so
that plays out and then the guy gives
them a card and says hey i have another
game for you if you want to play so the
guy's like all right i'll play he wants
to play the game he calls us all
mysterious he gets picked up in a van
and he gets knocked out when he wakes up
he's in this hangar with like 500 other
people dressed in these green jumpsuits
and they're gonna play a game you know
they're gonna they're all here to play a
game and they're all similar people
they're all degenerates they all have
they all need money they all did
something bad in their life where now
they're down on their luck uh and they
and you kind of follow some of the
stories and find out what's going on so
that the thing opens up where they're
playing a game the first game they play
is red light green light and there's six
games they have to play and this red
light green light and this isn't
necessarily a sp this is sort of a
spoiler but not really guys because you
need to understand the context and this
will make you want to watch the show
because i highly recommend that you
watch the show so all these people like
i say all these people are in debt so
they're playing red light green light
and so the guy is like so they're all in
line and you know how red light green
light works there's a big mechanical
machine that turns around and goes it's
a a woman it goes red light green light
so they say the instructions they go
you know
whoever is moving on red light will be
eliminated you know they say that let me
repeat the instructions we'll be
eliminated now all the workers are
dressed in with like masks you know what
i'm saying they're all like hooded with
masks and they got guns and they're
telling them like boom
and there's like they're in this like
open coliseum type thing and there's
like these little windows that are open
you don't see what's going on so the
first round red light green light so the
red light people stop but then there's
people that are moving and stuff right
and they start getting shot
like snipers are shooting all the people
that are moving and then there's mass
panic and it's just like
and like 200 300 people are just
instantly slaughtered now the other
people that are still there they figure
the [ __ ] out they're like oh [ __ ] we got
to stop moving and then so then that
plays out okay
and that's what squid games is about
these six games and you follow these
characters to find out like how it ends
and i'm telling you this show gets
better the acting gets better like the
guy the main character guy he really
plays this at first this really over the
top sort of like clownish character but
when these things what happens to him
and
what he turns into towards the end of
the show
i commend this guy i don't know his name
it's probably something korean and he's
got like a probably an american korean
name too for all we know but it actually
is really good and it's really
fascinating it's like a psychological
thing that happens to everybody in this
thing and then there's this cop who like
and then you know you'll see
i won't spoil it but squid games is
worth the watch
so it's what you want to do if you
either want to read the show and you
want to watch it in korean
um you know i might actually watch it
again like that since i've seen it in
english with no subtitles
i'll probably watch it again in korean
just because i bet you it's better
just because you like it feels just more
natural the voices that are coming out
and how they're doing it you know i'll
probably watch it again but i still
enjoyed it watching it in english
because i don't like reading my movies
you know i just don't like that so
make sure you uh check out squid games
everybody you know
check out
check out the squid
games
all right guys well um we did it we did
it again
uh
that's another uh episode of uh roofing
with uh griffin
you know and
once again as i say if you have like a
picture
of some environment that you would like
to be the background of my podcast just
send it you can email me at eric eric
griffin.com or you could uh just you
know on instagram send me a message and
uh rachel started an instagram account
called i hate my boyfriend's couch
and so that's on instagram so check that
out and you can send pictures of your
boyfriend's couch or your girlfriend's
couch or just a shitty couch and she'll
post that on there so that's something
i'm gonna be doing you know so again
send me a picture that you would like to
uh see
you know your
your um
background of roofing with griffin so
that's what that'll be right there uh
once again we talked about this week you
know make sure you check out squid games
on netflix
watch the terrible movie the voyur it's
on amazon even though i spoiled the [ __ ]
out of it
counterpart on amazon i think is really
great it's a slow show but i do think
you'll enjoy it get yourself a squatty
potty you know and uh shout out once
again to doordash and manscape for being
sponsors of the show this has been
riffing with griffin episode
153
[Music]
and
i will see you
next
week
thanks for watching the show y'all